- Today on "Drew," we're flashing back
to our favorite moments from Season One.
- "I have a date with Lisa!"
- "Lisa!" (screams)
Only Eddie Murphy could
get me literally rolling
on the floor, plus our
two-week premier event starts
Monday from Hollywood.
We're revealing superstar guests,
like one of the most talented singers
in the world, Billie Eilish.
It all starts now!
(upbeat music)
- [Announcer] Please
welcome Drew Barrymore!
(audience cheers)
- Hello, everyone, Season Two
of our first show is just four days away.
On Monday, September 13th,
we're kicking off a brand
new season full of surprises,
signature segments,
and yes, stain removal!
(audience laughs)
The stain busting will
never stop, don't you worry!
All right, we're having a
big two-week premier event,
paying homage to all of
our favorite hometowns,
and that feeling that
there's no place like home?
Well, we're starting in my own town of LA
and we're ending up here
in our show's hometown
and my new hometown of New York City.
(audience cheers)
I know!
I do heart New York.
(man laughs)
This week, we're having a little pre-party
and celebrating our favorite
moments from Season One.
Let's kick things off with a
guest who had some great advice
about the importance of
celebrating ourselves,
and here's our very candid conversation
with the legendary, the hilarious,
and wise Eddie Murphy, take a look.
I was lucky enough
to meet our first guest when
I was just seven years old.
He was a couple of seasons
into his transformative run
on "Saturday Night Live,"
where he immortalized
characters like Mr. Robinson
and Gumby, but he was destined
for even greater things,
and he found them
as the star in some of the most
iconic comedies of all time.
Let's talk about "Trading Places."
Let's talk about "Beverly Hills Cop."
Let's talk about "Coming to America."
And he still pursued
his first love, standup,
and released two specials,
including the highest-grossing
stand-up comedy concert film
of all time.
And then, the father of
10 gifted his talents
to beloved family films
that shaped generations,
voicing characters in films like "Mulan"
and the "Shrek" franchise.
And now after celebrated performances
in 2006's "Dream Girls"
and 2019's "Dolomite Is My Name,"
he is returning to his kingdom, Zamunda,
as Prince Akeem in "Coming to America."
This is one my very favorite
movies of all times.
"I have a date with Lisa!"
(audience laughs)
I can't believe I'm saying
this in front of the person.
Please welcome the one
of a kind Eddie Murphy.
(audience cheers)
- Thank you, that is so nice.
You made me feel like I did
some good movies. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
Hi, Drew Barrymore!
- Hello, Eddie Murphy!
I'm so happy to see you.
- Yeah, happy to see you too.
- I mean, 1982.
- You were just a little baby-
- Yeah.
- When I met you.
- And there we were.
- Just a little baby!
(laughs) Aw!
- And look at you and I.
- [Eddie] You're just a baby. (laughs)
I'm young, too, I think
I'm 19 or 20 there.
- Yeah.
- I remember Tim Kazurinsky.
You guys were buddies that
week, became buddies with him.
- I did, I gravitated towards him.
He was so nice to me.
- Yeah, you guys were cute.
- Do you remember doing the "E.T." sketch?
You were Mr. T looking for his boy, E,
and I don't know if you remember this,
but Steven Spielberg was there.
He was very protective of me
at that time, I was so lucky.
- You know what's so strange
about that whole SNL experience?
It was so long ago,
so sometimes there'll be a sketch on,
and I won't even remember the sketch.
I'll be watching it, going,
"What is this sketch, what happens next?"
It's so much, it's so long ago,
and so many sketches in
between that and so much stuff,
a lot of times, I don't remember it.
I don't remember that Mr. T sketch.
- I just remember everything
from that show very vividly, but I, too,
have surrealistic gaps.
- Yeah, it's surreal.
Yeah, I can imagine.
You were a little baby when you started.
- Well, and that was in 1982.
- You were just a baby.
(Eddie laughs)
- I know,
and you have 10 kids,
so I can only imagine
what your perspective is now,
'cause I have two daughters,
and my perspective is
completely different now
than when I was seven.
- No, I mean, a totally different,
not just 10 kids, I have
my first grandchild now.
(Drew gasps)
- (squeals) Congratulations!
(audience applauds)
- Now, I'm a Papa, she
calls me Papa. (laughs)
- Oh, that's so wonderful.
I was reading that you said
your house is just a hub of activity
and that you like to hear the
voices just all over the place
and how proud you are of your kids,
and all 10 turned out
really wonderful people.
- Yeah, my favorite thing of all is
to have no schedule, have
nothing that I have to do,
and I'm home and all my
kids and all their friends,
they're all around, and I can
hear where everybody's at.
That's nirvana for me. (laughs)
- And I was reading
that you lean into
being a spiritual person
and being centered,
and that you said maybe you
avoided some of the pitfalls
that were so easy at your
disposal, if you will,
because of spirituality.
Is that true?
- Yeah, I'm very grounded spiritually,
and not so much in any religion,
just a connection with God.
Being a young person in
this business, it's a lot.
It's like you gotta navigate
through a minefield.
There's so many ways you
could just destroy yourself.
A lot of the people that I've seen
that destroyed themselves,
a lot of my contemporaries,
are the people like Michael
and Prince and Whitney
and people that came on the
scene around the same age
that I am.
- Yeah.
- It was this self-destructive
thing that they had.
That's my biggest blessing,
that I got started really early,
I knew what I wanted to
do really, really young,
and that I love myself.
I never hated myself, I
never beat up on myself.
I've always been my biggest fan. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
- I love that, you deserve to be,
'cause we're all there with you.
What would you say to
someone who does struggle
with, call it self-love?
I'm asking for myself, 'cause
I love and respect myself,
but I fall off the wagon
with total (laughs) self-flagellation
and being too hard and not
meeting my own expectations.
Do you have any advice for me?
- It's an inward search
and it's personal and it's
just between you and you,
and the outside stuff,
I don't let anything
that's not constructive,
I don't let anything negative in.
You have to train yourself
to turn away from it.
When negative stuff comes in,
stuff that's not constructive,
you have to turn from it.
You're here, and then you're blessed.
You're here and you're blessed?
You already won,
so the negative energy,
there's no time for that.
You won already.
You know what you should do every morning?
- What?
- You should do
a victory dance, you should
wake up every morning
and do the Drew Barrymore victory dance.
(everyone laughs)
"I won!"
You've won, mama.
- I feel like the world's
biggest winner right now
to hear such salient advice
from someone I have respected
so much my whole life,
and in 1982, when we did
"Saturday Night Live" together,
then you had done "48 Hours,"
"Trading Places," "Beverly
Hills Cop," by the way.
- And "Delirious" right
in the middle of that.
The red leather suit is right
in the middle of that stuff.
- [Drew] And at what exact point was "Raw"
to that?
- Right after "Coming
"to America" is "Raw."
- Oh, yeah, so that's '87.
- I can tell, 'cause I have a perm.
(audience laughs)
(laughs) That hair.
- You had such a succession
of these epic films.
You're so young.
Do you ever come down
from those periods of time
where you have hit after hit after hit
and you're working, working, working?
- I'll tell you what happened to me.
I had it all the way together
for years and years and years,
and then what happened with movies is
they started offering you
so much money to do stuff
that I wound up doing all,
you know what that's like?
You would just do it and be like,
"Hey, you wanna give me that
much money to do that (beep)?"
"Okay."
(everyone laughs)
A bunch of movies like
that, and it's forever.
(laughs) Way after the money is spent,
that (beep) movie is still
playing on a movie channel.
(laughs) So I got to
where I stopped having
fun making movies,
so I had to take a time off.
In 2011, I think it was,
I stopped for eight years.
I just stopped making movies,
and that's where I had
really, really quiet time
and got re-centered
to where if I'm gonna be doing something,
I wanna be doing it because I wanna do it,
and I got it all back together that way.
- That is the perfect
answer to that question,
and the reason I asked is
because, since that 1982 time,
and I had even been working
before that and so had you,
but we're still here, we're still going.
It's 30, 40 years later.
- That's what I said.
That's why I said you should do
the victory dance, how about this?
We're in the business, Drew,
where people come and go.
Every five years, there's a
brand new bunch of new faces,
and anybody that's in this business
for as long as you've
been in this business,
as long as I've been in this business,
I think that means that we're not stinky.
(everybody laughs)
It's been firmly established
that we are not stinky.
(audience applauds)
- It was very special advice
to hear from Eddie,
and the truth is I still
forget it all the time.
I need to write it on my
wall because he's right.
We don't feel like we
have accomplished enough
or that we're there at those goal lines.
We (pounding fist) push and push and push
and really take ourselves down,
and we need to lift
ourselves up, all right?
I love that advice from Eddie.
All right, now sit tight because
we're just getting started.
There's more Eddie Murphy
and behind-the-scenes tidbits
to his famous films in just a minute.
(upbeat music)
We'll be right back.
(audience cheers)
- "I have a date with Lisa,"
will you say it with me?
- Or how about I say it like this?
"I have a date with Lisa?"
No, I'll do it the right way.
- "I have a," I know, I-
- "I have a date with Lisa!"
- "Lisa!" (screams)
(audience cheers)
(Eddie laughs)
- Now if I'd known you
was gonna roll around,
I'd have did it the first time.
(Drew laughs)
(audience laughs)
(upbeat music)
♪ If you're into fashion
or easy home decor ♪
♪ New favorite recipes ♪
♪ Plus fun celebrities ♪
(celebrities laugh)
♪ Need a little good news ♪
- We're back to bring you more.
♪ Barrymore ♪
♪ Drew's all new for Season Two, yeah ♪
♪ Life improving, stain removing ♪
♪ Barrymore ♪
- [Announcer] The new season
of "Drew" premieres September 13th.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauds)
- Welcome back.
We're checking out some of
the most memorable moments
from Season One, curated just for you,
of "The Drew Barrymore Show,"
with bonus director's cut commentary
from someone with a unique
firsthand perspective, me.
Now let's jump back into our
conversation with Eddie Murphy,
where I may or may not
have gotten him to do
one of my favorite lines
that I say every day
from "Coming to America!"
Okay, spoiler alert, I did, take a look!
One of my favorite movies of all time is
"Coming to America."
"Coming to America 2" is here,
and we can all finally go back to Zamunda.
Was there a moment where you said,
"Now is the right time
to make this sequel?"
- No, it happened organically, this movie,
the way it came together,
because the way the story ended,
it was, "And they live
happily ever after,"
and we didn't even think
about making a sequel,
but then the movie became a cult movie.
Little stuff from the
movie just stayed around.
Of all the movies that I've done,
no movie is on TV as much
as "Coming to America."
It's always on and little
lines from the movie,
and, "Sexual Chocolate!"
(audience laughs)
People say (laughs) that, little lines-
- Definitely.
- From the movie,
or the mic drop that everybody does.
The very first mic drop
ever is Randy Watson
from "Coming to America,"
all this little stuff from the movie.
And then what happened,
about 10 years ago,
some people on Halloween would
dress up as the characters,
and there's a restaurant in LA
that, on Halloween, it
changes itself into McDowell's
and they have a McDowell's menu,
so it really is this cult movie.
So it became that, and that's
when I started having the idea
of, hey, well, the people
that really, really like
that movie might wanna see a sequel to it.
And then, when we figured
out a way to connect the dots
and to make it make sense,
then we wrote a script
and it came together right.
- Can I ask a burning question
that I've wondered ever
since I first saw the movie,
which is the little
child on the skateboard,
because they've all taken the suitcases
and they're wearing all
the fabulous Zamunda garb,
was it like, "Let's just say
that we have so much clothes
"that there are child's
sizes," or, "Screw it.
"Tailor it, it's funnier?"
- No, we were taking
license there, 'cause I
know it's (laughs) a kid
and he has on a child's size.
(audience laughs)
You have to remember, now,
the movie was a comedy,
and it was directed by
the great John Landis.
People, when they talk
about "Coming to America,"
when I'm asked about "Coming to America,"
they get me and Arsenio,
the actors that get all
the credit for the movie,
and that movie is
more John Landis than anything.
And that's a John Landis joke,
to have the kid go skating by.
In the moment, he probably was like,
"Hey, have a kid skateboard by there."
(laughs) He's like that.
- It's my favorite moment,
other than, of course,
the quote of, "I have a date with Lisa,"
and I say it every day
because it's my version
of showing that I'm happy.
- Aw, that's wonderful.
- (laughs) Oh, we have the clip!
May we show it, please?
- I have a date with Lisa!
Isn't that wonderful?
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
- That scene right there,
the little girls that are in that scene,
was a friend of mine named Jeffrey Moore
who lived in Brooklyn, and he
stopped by the set that day,
and the little girl in
the light blue jacket,
that was his daughter and
she was just with him.
We just put her in the scene
(snaps fingers) right there.
It just happened at that moment.
- Would you ever say it with
me, will you say it with me?
- Or how about I say it like this?
(laughs) "I have a date with Lisa."
(everybody laughs)
"I have a date with Lisa?"
No, I'll do it the right way.
- "I have a," I know, I-
- "I have a date with Lisa!"
- "Lisa!" (screams)
(audience cheers)
(Eddie laughs)
- Now if I'd known you
was gonna roll around,
I'd have did it the first time.
(Drew laughs)
(audience laughs)
- Eddie, I'm so happy to see you.
Thank you for giving me such incredible,
salient life advice.
- It's nice to see you,
too, and I look forward to,
after all this pandemic stuff is over,
come there and see you live in person.
(Drew sighs)
(audience cheers)
- I will roll myself up
in this carpet for you.
I'll be a burrito
(Eddie laughs)
by the time we finish, and I
will dance that victory dance
and recognize the purpose.
- Even if you don't do
it physically, get right.
Always start the day
with, "I've already won.
"At this game, I've already won."
Now it's just about getting
the most out of everything,
being here and your
babies and your family.
- I very much recognize
that, and I love it coming
from the person who has
made life make sense
for so many of us on this planet
by helping us love and
laugh and enjoy life
and fall in love with the
extraordinary characters
that are you that you've
put out into the world.
Thank you.
- Thank you so much.
(audience cheers)
- (exclaims) Only Eddie Murphy could get
me literally rolling on the floor
like the carpet was a burrito!
(audience laughs)
All right,
more of our favorite moments
when we return, don't move!
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
♪ If you're into fashion
or easy home decor ♪
♪ New favorite recipes ♪
♪ Plus fun celebrities ♪
(celebrities laugh)
♪ Need a little good news ♪
- We're back to bring you more.
♪ Barrymore ♪
♪ Drew's all new for Season Two, yeah ♪
♪ Life improving, stain removing ♪
♪ Barrymore ♪
- [Announcer] The new season
of "Drew" premieres September 13th.
(upbeat music)
- Cookbooks are my obsession,
and it turns out I'm
not alone, watch this!
- My Cookbook Club is
Ina Garten, Barefoot Contessa,
"Modern Comfort Food."
It has everything you exactly
wanna be eating right now,
and you might look up the best tomato soup
with a grilled cheese,
but Ina always makes it
that much easier to make
and with an ingredient you
wouldn't have expected,
so it's that much more
delicious, it is ideal!
She does this chicken breast with orzo
that I did on my pretend cooking show,
and I've made my chicken breasts that way
so many times since then,
and I made it last night,
and my kids and I were just
like, "This is delicious,"
and all the desserts,
the way she does potatoes in
that cookbook, her veggies.
Ina Garten, Barefoot Contessa,
"Modern Comfort Food,"
favorite cookbook right now.
- Thank you for joining in
my obsession with cookbooks.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauds)
- Welcome back
to our Season Two pre-party.
We're checking out some of our
favorite Season One moments
and letting you in on
behind-the-scenes secrets
ahead of our Season
Two premiere next week.
One of my favorite parts of
this job is getting to meet
so many incredible and inspiring
people from everywhere,
and this person who's coming
up next really, really affected
me, I love her.
Debra Houston is a mother,
grandmother, great grandmother,
and get this, the oldest
Soap Box Derby racer
in the country, take a look.
Here she is, it's Debra!
(audience cheers)
- Hi, Drew!
- Hi, Debra!
I'm so excited to meet you.
- And I'm excited to meet you, too!
- How did you end up
getting into soapbox racing?
- Well, Indianapolis is
known for the racing,
and a friend of mine had approached me
about taking my grandchildren
to do the soapbox racing.
And so I thought it would
be a good thing for them
to get them off the computers,
it'll teach them responsibility,
and give them something
to do during the pandemic.
So I took them to practice
and they met their coach, Mr. Larry,
and Mr. Larry kept
approaching me about racing.
He said, "You're the perfect size.
(audience laughs)
"You could fit in that car."
He said, "Come on, do it,"
and I kept thinking about it
and thinking about it, and I finally said,
"Okay, I'll try it."
(audience applauds)
- [Drew] I love it because, I mean,
I learned that the oldest soapbox racer
in your team is 14, right?
(man laughing)
- Right.
- I just love this!
This is so cool!
(Debra laughs)
Tiny, but mighty!
- Yes! (laughs)
- What was going through your head
the first time you were like-
- Well, at first, I was a little nervous,
and I was hyperventilating
because I was so nervous.
And I went down that hill,
and when I went down that hill,
I said, "Oh, I can do this,"
and I started practicing and
kept going down that hill,
and it turned out to be fun!
At the same time, I was
going through chemo,
so I said, "Well, rather than
sit up and worry about chemo,
"I could be practicing and having fun
"and just doing this
with my grandchildren,"
and I really enjoyed it!
(audience applauds)
- [Drew] And is it true
that you're doing fantastically well now?
- Yes, I am cancer-free.
(Drew cheers)
(audience cheers)
- Yes.
(Drew exclaims)
- I asked that right
away when I found out,
and it's just so important,
and your story, your attitude,
the fact that you wanna get
your kids out off the technology
and out into the world
during the pandemic,
the fact that you had cancer
and were going through this,
but chose to spend your time
doing and focusing on this,
you are the example.
- Well, thank you, Drew,
(clapping) thank you!
- It's true.
- I wanna be.
- You are, what's next for you?
What else are we gonna learn from you?
- Well, I'm gonna go race this 2021,
and this year, I'm gonna win.
(audience cheers)
So those are my goals,
to race and to win in 2021.
- [Drew] Well, you are the biggest winner,
and we wanna be cheering you on,
and I have a little something for you.
- Oh, really, for me?
- Yeah, this is a little-
- Oh, look, it's got my name on it!
- Oh, yeah, it does.
(Debra laughs)
(Debra clapping)
- I hope you don't mind.
We put a little logo of our show on there.
Here you go.
- Oh, my goodness,
that's a racing suit!
- And it's just perfectly your size,
and I will say it's sturdy,
but it's also really soft.
- Oh, my goodness, thank you, Drew!
- It is such a pleasure,
but that's not all.
Check this out.
So we know you live in Indianapolis,
so we reached out to the Indy 500.
When they heard about you,
they wanted to give you
a few things, as well.
So they wanna have you wave-
- Oh, my goodness.
the green flag
(Debra gasps)
for the Indy 500 practice day.
(audience cheers)
Yeah, that's right.
- (clapping) Oh, goodness, Drew!
- [Drew] How cool is that?
And they also want-
- This is really cool.
Oh, that just makes me feel so good.
Thank you.
- Well, they also wanna put
your soapbox on display
in their fan area on actual race day
and host you and all your grandchildren
on practice day-
- Oh, thank you.
(audience cheers)
- And show you off
like a little Debra museum!
- Thank you so much!
- Oh, Debra, do you mind
if we speak to you again
and ask you how that day
went and just check in?
- Yes, oh, you can.
Please, please call me, I'll call you!
- Okay, good, I'm so relieved.
(Debra laughs)
I'm like, Debra, I need more.
I wanna catch up and
see how that day went,
and thank you to the Indy 500
who gets it-
- Thank you!
- Wants to honor Debra, we
honor you here at this show.
We love you, and I can't thank you enough
for being here to be that example.
- Well, thank you, Drew,
and thank you for having me,
and thank you for all of that.
Thank you so much.
- Oh, thank you, Debra!
(audience applauds)
Debra is the best,
and we followed up with her
after her big day at the Indy
500, and she told us she felt
like a true celebrity and queen that day.
And they actually showed
her "Drew Barrymore Show" appearance
on the big screens at the race track,
and she said all the
professional drivers were asking
to take pictures with her.
So fun and just so deserved.
We're rooting for you, Debra.
More behind the scenes
in just a minute, okay?
We'll see you in a second,
hopefully, all right, bye.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
Welcome back, do you ever watch our show
and wonder what happens after
the cameras stop rolling?
Well, all week long, we're revisiting
some of our favorite Season One moments
and sharing behind-the-scenes
bonus commentary.
I don't know if you know,
but I am a beauty junkie,
so I always look forward
to our segment called Beauty in a Box,
where I get to customize
the perfect beauty routine
for one of you and send
it right to your door
in a care package and
then take you through it.
And our first-ever Beauty
in a Box segment was
with a viewer named
Daniella who wrote to us
with a very relatable beauty dilemma.
Take a look.
- Hi, Drew, my name is Daniella.
I'm 40 years old.
I live in Illinois.
I am a working mom with four kids.
I need some help with makeup.
I need a five-minute routine
that will enhance the most features,
'cause five minutes is
about as much time as I have
with four kids and working.
Also, if you could help me with mascara,
I hate putting it on, it smudges,
and I look like a raccoon within an hour.
It's just underneath my eyes.
So if I have to wear it,
please teach me how to use it.
Thank you, and I really need your help.
(audience applauds)
- Daniella, I have to tell
you, you are so beautiful.
I've seen your video before,
but as I'm rewatching it, I'm
just like, you're so pretty.
- Thank you! (laughing)
That's a very big compliment
coming from Drew Barrymore!
- Well, what I put together for you,
do you have a box in front of you?
We sent you some beauty products.
(cheers) All right.
- I do. (laughs)
- This is Beauty in a Box.
Shall we open it together?
- Yes, please.
- Okay.
So what I got for you first
is, I love the company Kiehl's,
and this is a Skin Tone
and Beautifying BB Cream,
but it also has sunscreen.
Do you wear sunscreen?
- I do, that's probably the only thing
that I'm very consistent about. (laughs)
- Oh, my God, I'm so proud
of you and happy for you
because I'm terrible about it.
Unless I'm going into
the sun, I always forget.
So tinted moisturizers and light BB creams
with sunscreen are just
great for daily wear,
and they're gonna be a really light layer.
You can literally put it into
your hands like a moisturizer
and then do the pat, pat, pat,
and then you'll go under the eyes,
and you can always add more.
You look amazing!
- This feels really nice.
- Wow!
- That's crazy! (laughs)
- Okay, (clapping) I am
so pleased.
- That's already different.
- What do you think, do you like it?
- Well, it's nice because it's light.
It feels really nice on.
It's very moisturizing.
- Okay.
Now next, what I got you,
this is a company called
AMAZING, AMAZINGCONCEALER,
and this is for if you ever
have more sleepless nights
or you're just a little more
exhausted or you get a blemish,
and what's nice is that the
pigment is nice and heavy,
so it'll cover up dark circles or a spot,
but it's very blendable on the edges.
Otherwise, you're gonna see the circle.
Under my eyes?
- Yeah,
just a teeny dot, dot, dot,
and then you can work it in
with your fingers, very minimal.
This is for those Cryptkeeper days
when the kids have exhausted you.
Oh, my God, you look so
beautiful, I'm so excited!
I swear, I feel like, I don't know.
I feel like an artist right
now and like I'm painting you,
and I'm like, look at this, a
painting, she's so beautiful!
(audience laughs)
Oh, my God,
I'm so happy right now, 'cause
you were already so beautiful
and I want things that will not take away
from your natural beauty.
Okay, this one is actually
from FLOWER Beauty.
It's called Gel Crush, and
the reason I love this,
it's brand new for our company.
You take it off, it's great for the bag.
I also love a good purse-friendly makeup.
When you have a foundation
the size of this,
you're probably not
throwing it in your purse.
So this is dot, dot, dot,
dot, dot, dot and a
little smudge on the lips,
just so if you want a pop of color,
you know you can get it out of this.
Oh, Daniella, you are looking so foxy!
I'm so pleased right now, I
feel like a proud peacock.
(audience laughs)
- Is it too much or no?
- No, not at all, that's great,
and then work it all over the lips,
like a deodorant fell in love
with a lipstick and had a baby.
(Daniella laughs)
(audience laughs)
Yes, oh, that just gave
that perfect little kick,
where it picks up your natural pigment.
The thing that I care the most
about with FLOWER Beauty is
that it will never leave a woman hanging.
When we have a formula,
it never gathers or goes in the cracks.
The pigment just goes
away, the hydration stays.
Okay, next from FLOWER, I
got you our Lash Warrior,
and the reason I love this is
it looks like a weapon because it is.
It is an amazing mascara,
and it actually has a rubber wand,
which is gonna distribute
through the lash differently
and it's gonna lead to less flakeage.
I think you're doing a phenomenal job.
Okay, now at the end,
I put this in special.
This is micellar water.
I discovered this
because all the people
in the fashion industry
for the runway fashion
shows were using this,
'cause they could take off all
the makeup in one fell swoop.
And it used to only be
available in France,
and now micellar waters
are always on trend.
So this is a Garnier.
You can find this anywhere.
So when you're done with all of this,
you wanna put this on the pad
and you wanna just take everything off
and make it nice and clean and clear.
No matter what you do, do not
go to bed with your makeup on.
- No, it's usually pretty easy,
'cause I normally don't wear makeup,
(laughs) but no, I do wash.
I do have a good cleansing routine.
It's just the makeup, I
have a hard time with it,
but this is something I
can totally do on my own
and quick with four
kids, thank you so much.
- That's exactly the point,
(audience applauds)
natural, fast, and absolutely beautiful.
You already were, and
this just enhances that,
and really, the whole point
of beauty is how you feel.
And if something happens where
it boosts the way you feel,
that is the whole point,
as far as I'm concerned.
- Thank you so much.
This was great, I feel great.
(audience applauds)
- Yay, Daniella, and you,
please keep writing us
with your beauty dilemmas
because we'll be sending out
more beauty boxes in Season
Two and I cannot wait.
Let me be your personal beauty junkie!
All right, more fun from Season One
in just a second, as they say.
Stay right there, we'll be right back.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
Welcome back, we're getting ready
for our Season Two premiere next week
by looking back on some
of our favorite moments
from Season One, with
some fun bonus facts.
As a business owner
myself, I am so passionate
about highlighting
inspiring entrepreneurs,
and when we heard about Cindy Tawiah,
we knew that we had to talk to her.
She is a beauty brand founder who launched
the first-ever natural
haircare vending machines
in the U.S., and her genius idea
to put her products in
a vending machine came
as a result of a disappointing
setback that she faced.
Talk about ingenuity.
I do believe that failure
can lead to success,
and there is no success without failure.
Check out our conversation with Cindy
and the special surprise
that we had in store for her.
Please welcome Cindy Tawiah!
(audience cheers)
- Hi, Cindy!
- Hi, Drew, hi, Ross!
- Hi, (laughs) oh, my God.
You're cute, I just gotta tell you.
- Oh, thank you! (exclaims)
(Ross laughs)
- Your products are
in Sally's Beauty
Supplies and walmart.com,
and so are we at FLOWER Beauty,
so I'm very happy to be
sisters in business with you.
- Aw, thank you, Drew.
- [Drew] I've looked into
getting a vending machine,
and it is no easy feat!
- Oh, my goodness, Drew.
Well, I had a wonderful,
successful, thriving, booming store
at BWI Airport, and I put that store there
because TSA takes away
all our haircare products,
and it's so traumatic.
- Oh, my God.
- I know you've been
through it, sister girl.
- Yeah, when you go through,
they look at the ends and they're like,
"You can't take this through."
- Yeah.
- Yes, so I opened the store,
everything was going great,
and then one day, they took away my store.
It was like, "We're reclaiming the space,"
and I was devastated.
I had to lay everybody off
and literally close my
store, and you know what?
A girl's gotta get on her feet.
After a few months, I went
right back to that airport,
met with the CEO, Mr. Ricky,
put my PowerPoint presentation
in his face, and I said,
"This is what I wanna bring
here," and he looked at me.
He said, "Young lady,
you're very persistent.
"How many airports do you want?
"How many concourses do you want?"
I said, "That's it, amen, we're in."
(Ross laughs)
So that's
how that all started.
(everyone applauds)
- I love that!
- And I did my research
and engineered it, but girls
have gotta get creative.
They take away from you,
you gotta figure out how to bring it back.
- Yeah, you gotta pivot
if you wanna be successful.
(Cindy laughs)
And I know your business-
- That's right!
- It is successful-
- Pivot!
- And a core part of it is
not only providing products
for women, but taking
care of women, as well.
Why is that important to you?
- Oh my God, Ross, I'm a
survivor of domestic violence,
but one of the things that's
very, very important is
we donate 10% of our proceeds
to homeless shelters,
and then we do beauty makeovers.
It's called the Diva Project,
where we go out and we give
them a full beauty makeover,
and it's so important for us
to give back to our community,
and especially women who
are hurting and broken.
(audience applauds)
- Right, I mean, I'm done.
(claps) I love you.
- I just have so much admiration for you,
I don't know where to begin.
- Aw, thank you so much, and I you,
because sisters have to
take care of sisters.
Women have to pour into each other
instead of tearing each other down.
We have to build each other
up, that's how we rise.
- Well, you're such a caretaker.
I mean, you weren't always in
the beauty industry, right?
You were a nurse for 13 years.
- Yes, I was a nurse for 13 years,
and what led me to this point
was I had a chemistry teacher
who taught me how to make
nail polish and lipstick
when I was 16 years old
in Ghana, West Africa.
This teacher, Mr. Ofei, he
saw that I was struggling,
and instead of giving me another F,
(laughing) which I had
been getting, by the way,
(Ross laughs)
he said, "Young lady,
"I'm gonna teach you how to
make nail polish and lipstick,
"and you're gonna learn to love my class,"
and then when he was done,
he had me be part of the science fair.
That was for the bright,
intelligent students,
not for dodos like me.
So of course, at the science
fair, he presented me
as a cosmetologist and a
chemist, and I thought,
"Oh, my God, that's what I
wanna be when I grow up."
I went home and told my daddy.
He said, "No, you are going
into the medical field.
"I didn't send you to school
"so that you could go
and do the beauty thing,"
and I thought, "Wow."
So fear shot me down, I stayed in nursing,
and 13 years later, I got my wings!
I got my courage and I left nursing
to pursue my passion and my purpose,
and that's why I'm here today.
I had to change my focus
to change my future.
- Wow. (claps)
(Drew claps)
(audience cheers)
- I love that!
- Actually, Mr. Ofei has
a message for you.
Go ahead and roll the clip, please.
- Hi, Cindy, I'm very proud of you
and all your accomplishments.
- God!
- And I do hope
that you continue to be an inspiration
for all young girls-
- Oh, my God!
- Around the world and
continue to inspire them
to achieve their goals.
(Cindy crying)
Congratulations.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you!, oh, my God!
Oh, my God!
I'm sorry, oh, my God!
He saved my life and the
lives of so many other women!
Oh, my God, thank you,
Drew, he saved my life,
and because of him, so many
women have been touched
because of one person
having faith in another.
I'm sorry, oh, my God!
- Don't be sorry!
I feel like such a lucky fly on the wall
of this moment that you so deserve.
- Oh, my God!
- (laughs) Aw!
- Drew, thank you!
- Cindy, I just can't wait
to see what you do next,
and please, let's stay friends
and in touch and continue
to shine a light on
everything that you're doing,
because I just think the world
of you, and you can check out
her products online at divabycindy.com.
And thank you for being on the show.
(audience cheers)
Thank you.
- (claps) So proud of you.
- Thank you so much, Drew.
Thank you so, so much,
and I would definitely
love to connect with you
and help you with your vending
machine, I'm here for you.
- Great!
- Yeah, I need-
- Yes.
- Your guidance,
'cause I totally couldn't pull
it off, thank you so much.
I think you have a lot
to teach me, Cindy.
- I'm available!
(audience applauds)
- What an inspirational,
wonderful, awesome woman.
We chatted with Cindy recently,
and she has not slowed down.
She launched one of her vending machines
on a military base in Virginia,
and Mr. Ofei has asked her to
mentor some of his students.
I love this, we'll be right
back to spill some more secrets
about Season Two, don't go anywhere.
(upbeat music)
We're gonna spill.
(audience cheers)
Gonna talk.
♪ If you're into fashion
or easy home decor ♪
♪ New favorite recipes ♪
♪ Plus fun celebrities ♪
(celebrities laugh)
♪ Need a little good news ♪
- We're back to bring you more.
♪ Barrymore ♪
♪ Drew's all new for Season Two, yeah ♪
♪ Life improving, stain removing ♪
♪ Barrymore ♪
- [Announcer] The new season
of "Drew" premieres September 13th.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
- Thank you for checking out
some of our favorite Season One moments.
Season Two kicks off Monday,
and we'll be coming to you
from Los Angeles all week long,
and we have so many
surprises in store for you.
Should I spoil a couple now?
(audience cheers)
All right!
Well, we're dedicating one day
next week to all things Emmy
with our friends from
"Entertainment Tonight,"
and this year's Emmy Emcee
is Cedric the Entertainer!
(audience cheers)
I know, I love him
and Kevin and Michelle!
Plus the super talented
Billie Eilish is stopping by.
(Drew squeals)
(audience cheers)
She has two number-one
albums under her belt
at age 19 and just so much more.
I mean, people wear T-shirts with her.
She means so much to people, including me,
and I'm really looking forward
to sitting down with her.
(exclaims) Okay, and we'll be back
with more memorable moments
and behind-the-scenes secrets tomorrow,
and mark your calendars for
the big Season Two premiere
on Monday, September 13th.
I love Mondays!
(audience cheering)
See you then!
(upbeat music)
(bright music)
(plucky music)